In terms of human ancestry, genomic data has
helped reinforce a theory that humans have
spread out across the globe from Africa in
the recent past.
This has led to a large number of variants
that are shared across the globe and fluctuate
in only subtle levels.
Those fluctuations though are very geographic
in their nature, such that individuals that
are closer together have much more similar
allele frequencies.
That can be used to reconstruct population
movements and even individual-level ancestry
of where someone's grandparents or great-grandparents
come from.
The other major signal that we've been learning
about using genomic data is about how the
human population has been growing in many
places throughout the globe.
That growth has been tied with the appearance
of many new rare variants that are geographically localized.
And an exciting area is using those rare variants
to uncover very recent time period migration patterns.